PROFESSOR: Resume by going back
to our one-dimensional
body that has undergone some
elastic deformation.
And what I would like to do now
is to distinguish between
displacement of an object and
fractional change of length,
which turned out to be measured
by the same thing,
that thing that we're
going to name strain
when properly defined.
OK, here is our one-dimensional
case.
And we said that originally some
point, P, at a location x
gets mapped to a point P prime
that is at x plus some
displacement U. So this is the
displacement vector U.
Our point Q, which is originally
at some location x
plus delta x, where delta x
is the original separation
between P and Q, gets mapped to
a point Q prime, which is
going to be equal to a whole
collection of terms.
It's going to be equal to x
plus delta x, the original
location, plus the linear
variation of U with x that has
to go U times x plus delta x.
And if we simplify this a little
bit, Q prime is going
to be at a location, factoring
out x plus delta x, x plus
delta x times 1 plus e.
AUDIENCE: Is e represented
here?
PROFESSOR: e is the linear
relation between displacement
U and position along the body.
OK, so what has happened here?
The relative change of length
is going to be P prime
Q prime minus PQ.
And if we just substitute in
our two expressions, the
relative change of length is
going to be equal to delta x
times 1 plus e minus delta x.
This is the relative
change of length.
And I should label this such.
That's going to be equal to
delta x times 1 plus e minus
delta x divided by delta x.
And that simply going to be
e, which is equal to delta
U over delta x.
And that is what we
define as strain.
And that is a dimensionless
quantity.
Because it has units of
length over length.
All right, how can we patch this
one-dimensional sort of
behavior up to a
three-dimensional situation?
What we are saying in this
one-dimensional case is that
the displacement of a particular
point P varies
linearly with position
in the body.
So let's generalize that into
three dimensions by saying
that the component of
displacement U1-- and this is
going to look like an
algebraic identity.
It's going to be the way in
which U changes with x1 times
the position x1.
So this is saying that the
displacement will vary
linearly with x1.
And the rate will be du1 dx1.
But also U1 is going to change
with the coordinate x2.
And the coefficient there
will be du1 dx2.
And there's going to be a third
term that will be the
way in which U1, the x1
component of displacement,
changes with x3 times the
position in the body x3.
So this is saying exactly the
same thing that we did in one
dimension, that displacement
depends linearly with
position, except that
there's now three
coordinates for position.
And the displacement will change
with an increment of a
change in position along each
of those three axes.
Similarly, we can say that U2
is going to be equal to the
way in which U2 changes with x1
times the position x1, the
way in which U2 changes with x2
times the coordinate within
the body x2, and the same for
U2 dx3 and the actual
positional coordinate x3.
And so, in general, we're going
to propose that the i-th
component of displacement is
given by the way in which
displacement changes with
x sub j times x sub j.
Or you could do the same thing,
not in terms of actual
displacement, but differences in
displacement, the same way
we could define strain as the
fractional change of length of
our line segment on the
elastic band or,
alternatively, as the
shift in position.
So we could define it also as
the difference in distances or
displacements let
me call them.
And that really is
a trivial change.
We'll say the change of a length
along x1 delta U1 is
going to be the way in which U1
changes with x1 times delta
x1 plus the way in which U2
changes with x1 times the way
in which U1 changes with x2
times delta x2 plus the way in
which U1 changes with x3 times
delta x3 or, in general, that
the fractional change in length
is going to be equal to
dui dxj times delta xj.
All right, so what we're going
to define now is dui.
Dxj will be defined as something
like strain.
It's not exactly strain yet.
And this is going to be a
measure of deformation.
I'm hedging my words because of
something that we'll want
to impose upon the proper
strain tensor.
But first, let's see what these
three-dimensional terms mean.
And to see that, let me look
at a place within the body.
And I'm going to look at a line
segment that goes between
a P and Q that is oriented
along x1.
And I'm picking that
deliberately.
Because I want to keep things
simple and isolate one of
these terms so we can identify
its meaning.
So let's say here we have two
points P and Q separated by a
distance delta x1 prior
to deformation.
And now we squish the body.
And what happens is that
P will move to
a position P prime.
Q will move to a position
Q prime.
And this will be the new line
segment, P prime Q prime.
This will be the original
delta x1.
To that we're going to
tack on an instrument
which is delta U1.
But then there will also
be a delta U2.
And clearly what has happened is
that the length of the line
segment P prime Q prime
has changed.
But also the orientation of the
line segment has changed
by an angle, which I'll
define as phi.
So again, we have
a line segment.
We deform the body.
P is displaced.
Q is displaced.
The component of that line
segment along x1 has changed
in length by an amount
delta U1.
The coordinate along x2 will
change by an amount delta U2.
So we not only change
the length.
But we rotate the
line segment.
We can express these in terms of
our general relation that I
proposed a moment ago.
Delta U1 is going to be equal
to du1 dx1 times delta x1.
And that is going to be given
by the element epsilon 1, 1
times delta x1.
The value of x2 was going
to be equal to du2
dx1 times delta x1.
And that's going to be
by definition e2,
1 times delta x1.
And the reason this is so simple
is that I initially
picked the line segment which
was parallel to x1.
So not all of the four terms
that would be present in the
x1, x2 system have come in.
So there's no contribution of
delta x2 because of the fact
that I've picked this
special orientation.
OK, the fractional change of
length resolved on x1 is going
to be, well, it's going to be
exactly delta x plus delta U1
quantity squared, it's going
to be this horizontal line
segment, plus delta U2
quantity squared all
to the power 1/2.
And now I'm going to say that
delta U2 is negligible
compared to this big delta
x plus delta U1.
And I'll say that this is
approximately equal to delta x
plus delta U1, OK, just taking
the whole works outside of the
square root sign.
So delta U1 over delta x1 is
going to be equal to the term
e1, 1 from this expression
here.
So the term e1, 1 represents the
tensile strain along x1.
So we can see how these
derivatives are going to enter
into changes of length.
The P prime Q prime has also
been rotated by phi.
And we can say exactly what that
is that the tangent of
phi is going to be given exactly
by delta U2 divided by
the original length of the line
segment delta x1 plus the
little increment of displacement
along x1.
And this is--
I'll walk down here
so I can see it.
This is delta U1.
This is delta U2 over
times delta x1--
sorry, I can't see what I've
got down here-- delta
U1 plus delta x1.
OK, so it's the amount of
displacement along x2 over the
original line segment delta
x1 plus the change in
displacement delta U1.
And clearly delta U1 can be
claimed to be small with
respect to delta x1.
So this is approximately equal
to delta U2 over delta x1.
And tangent of phi is going
to be tangent of
a very small angle.
So this will be delta
U2 over delta x1.
And so this angle phi is, for
small strains, going to be
equal to delta U2
over delta x1.
And that is the definition of
our element of strain e1, 2.
So e1, 2 corresponds to a
rotation of a line segment
that was originally parallel to
x1 in the direction of x2--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: e2, 1, I'm sorry, e2,
1, yeah, along x1 in the
direction of x2.
And that is counterintuitive as
I have just demonstrated.
e2, 1 is a rotation of a line
segment along x1 in the
direction of x2, which is just
the reverse of the subscript.
So eij, a general off-diagonal
element of the array eij, is
going to be a rotation of a line
segment initially along x
sub j in the direction
of x sub i.
And for very small strains,
numerically that term eij will
give an angle in radiants.
AUDIENCE: For the equation you
have over there, should it be
delta x plus delta x2?
PROFESSOR: No, I would
say this--
AUDIENCE: Because aren't
you saying delta U1?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK,
you're right.
Yeah, I didn't take the
difference here.
AUDIENCE: Delta U1 is basically
negligible?
PROFESSOR: Yep, yep, so I'm
saying that that [INAUDIBLE]
should be delta x1--
AUDIENCE: Plus delta U2?
PROFESSOR: --plus delta U2.
You're right.
No, I'm throwing this out.
And that's right.
So I'm saying that this
is essentially delta
x1 plus delta U1.
I'm saying that this
is negligible.
So strictly speaking the
distance between P prime and Q
prime is the square
root of this
squared plus this squared.
But if this thing is tiny, P
prime Q prime is essentially
going to be this distance,
delta x1 plus delta U1.
So that's right.
OK, so we have something that
looks like it measures
deformation.
But I would like to ask if this
is a suitable measure of
deformation.
And I would like to show that,
unless the tensor eij is
symmetric, that we have included
in our definition of
strain rigid body rotation as
well as true deformation.
So in order to demonstrate that,
what I'm going to look
at is a case where we have
actually, by the way in which
we apply a stress to the
material, actually done
nothing more than rotate
x1 to x1 prime and
rotate x2 to x2 prime.
And in general, for a real
amount of deformation, that is
something that is
going to happen.
Let's say I decide to deform
this eraser in shear before
your very eyes.
And I try shearing it.
Nothing much has happened.
And I squeeze a little harder.
And finally, I've got it
wrestled down into an
orientation like this.
And when I finished, this
was the original
position of the eraser.
Here's x1.
Here's x2.
And by the time I've wrestled it
around to a deformed state,
it sits down like this, maybe
deformed a little bit.
But would you say that this
angle here is a measure of
deformation?
No, that's clearly a rigid
body rotation.
And what I would intuitively
do, if I wanted to measure
true deformation, if this were
the original body and after
deformation it went to a
location with some deformation
to be sure but this has
been rotated to here.
This has been rotated down.
And I wouldn't want to say
that this is a measure of
deformation.
This would be e1, 2.
What I would want to do
intuitively would be to
position the body symmetrically
between the axes
and then say that this is a
measure of shear strain.
So let me show you now in a more
rigorous treatment that,
if there is a component of rigid
body rotation, let me
show you what a rotation of the
coordinate system to a new
orientation x1, x
prime would do.
So let's say that this is
an original point Q1.
And after deformation, it moves
by a rotation phi that's
equal to e2, 1 to a new
location Q1 prime.
Let's suppose that this
is a position Q2.
And after what we think is the
deformation, this moves to a
location Q2 prime.
And this would be e1, 2.
That's equal to minus phi.
This is e2, 1.
And that's equal to plus phi.
So what we would do is
like to get rid of
that rigid body rotation.
And what I'll do is to show
that, if we have a point
that's out at the end of a
radial vector, R, which has
coordinates xi, x1, x2, x3, and
if we have a displacement,
which is absolutely
perpendicular to that radial
vector, that this would
be characteristic
of rigid body rotation.
And I will say that, if Ui is
perpendicular to the radial
vector xi, then U.R should
be equal to 0 for
every position xi.
So if we just multiply this out,
this is saying that Ui Ri
should be equal to 0 for
rigid body rotation.
And let's simply carry
out this expansion.
And I will have then eij xi xj
forming this dot product.
And that is going to be 0 for
a rigid body rotation.
And if I expand this, this will
contain terms like e1, 1
times x1 x1 plus e2,
2 times x2 x2 plus
e3, 3 times x3 squared.
And then they'll be cross-terms
e1, 3 plus e3, 1
times x1 x3 plus e1, 2 plus e2,
1 times x1 x2 plus e2, 3
plus e3, 2 times x2, x3.
And my claim now is that, if
this represents rigid body
rotation, then that
should be 0.
That is to say the displacement
is absolutely
perpendicular to the radius
vector for small
displacements.
This must be 0 for all xi.
And the only way that's going
to be possible for any value
of x1, x2, x3 is that each
of these six terms vanish
individual.
It's the only way I'm going to
be able to get the whole thing
to disappear for any value
of coordinate x1, x2, x3.
So we're going to have to then
have e1, 1 equals e2, 2 equals
e3, 3 equals 0.
All the diagonal terms are
going to have to be 0.
In order to get the fourth term
to vanish, I'm going to
have to have e1, 3 equal to the
negative of e3, 1 and e1,
2 the negative of e2, 1 and e2,
3 the negative of e3, 2.
So what is this going to look
like for the part of the e
tensor that corresponds to
rigid body rotation?
The diagonal terms are
all going to be 0.
And the off-diagonal terms are
going to be the negative of
one another.
So this is e1, 2.
e2, 1 would have to be
equal to minus e1, 2.
e3, 1 would have to be equal
to the negative of e1, 3.
And so we will have something
like this.
So this suggests that our
definition of the true
deformation, which will be
a tensor epsilon ij--
I bet you kind of guessed I was
going to call it epsilon
and not E. I can write this
as a sum of two parts.
I'll turn that around and say
I'll write epsilon ij plus
another three by three array
omega ij is equal to the
tensor eij.
That's a novel idea.
This is addition of two tensors
element by element.
And if I do that and define
epsilon ij equal to 1/2 of eij
plus eji, so for the diagonal
elements that is going to take
1/2 of e1, 1 plus e1, 1.
And that's just going to give
me e 1, 1 back again.
And I'm going to define the
terms omega ij as 1/2
of eij minus eji.
And if I do that, the resulting
tensor will be symmetric.
OK, so from tensor eij we can
split it up into two parts and
a part omega ij.
And I won't bother
to write it out.
But you can see that omega ij
plus eij is going to be equal
to eij minus 1/2 of 2eij
minus 1/2 of 0.
And that's just going
to be eij.
So this plus this is indeed
going to give
me the tensor eij.
So given a tensor eij, which
is not symmetric, I will
define eij as the sum of two
parts, a tensor epsilon ij,
which is true strain, and a part
omega ij, which is rigid
body rotation.
And now at last we have a
satisfactory measure of true
deformation in terms of the
displacement of points within
a deformed body where that
displacement can arise from
either rigid body rotation
and or deformation.
So finally, we have a tensor
epsilon ij, which is the
strain tensor.
And now I can finally make my
claim that, if this really is
true deformation, that
for cubic crystals--
you can see the same
[INAUDIBLE]
window coming again--
since second ranked tensors have
to be symmetric for cubic
crystals, the form of
strain for a cubic
crystal can only be this.
It has to be diagonal
if the tensor is to
conform to cubic symmetry.
And you say, ah, ah, you tried
to pull that on us with
stress, too.
And I can squish a crystal
anyway I want.
But you can only develop
a strain if
you deform a crystal.
And the symmetry of the crystal
is going to determine
how the crystal deforms.
So therefore, a cubic crystal
should be able to deform only
in a way that stays invariant
to the transformations of a
cubic symmetry, right?
So cubic crystals can only
deform isotropically.
So if I wanted to design springs
for an automobile so
that elastic energy could be
stored most efficiently in a
solid, I would want to make
these automobile springs out
of a triclinic metal.
Because then the tensor could be
one of general deformation.
OK, well, this, obviously, is
a swindle like my assertion
that stress could only be an
isotropic compressional stress
for a cubic crystal.
But the argument is a little
more convoluted.
And strain, indeed, is
also a field tensor.
Because, even though I can only
create the deformation by
application of a stress or
perhaps an electric field or
something of that sort in that
the link between the
deformation and what I do to
the crystal is coupled by a
property of the crystal, which
has to conform to the symmetry
of the crystal, nevertheless,
given a tensor that describes
deformation, I can always,
independent of the symmetry of
the crystal, devise a particular
set of stresses
that would produce any state
of strain I want.
I would have to design, though,
a particular state of
stress to produce a desired
state of strain.
And that coupling has
to conform to the
symmetry of the crystal.
But there's no reason why strain
itself has to conform
to the symmetry of
the crystal.
I can create any state of strain
I like by choosing the
appropriate stress.
OK, so that is a swindle.
But everything now that I can
say about the behavior of a
second ranked tensor applies
to the strain tensor.
I can take a strain
tensor epsilon ij.
And I can perform the surface
epsilon ij xi xj equals 1.
And that will be the
strain quadric.
The strain quadric will have the
property like any quadric
constructed from a tensor that
the value of the radius in a
particular direction is going to
be such that the strain in
that direction is equal to 1
over the radius squared.
So what does that mean?
Well, we have to look at what
the strain tensor is relating.
The direction, remember now
that the definition of the
strain tensor is that U
sub i equals epsilon
ij times x sub j.
So the quote "applied vector"
is the direction in a solid.
And we will get, in general, a
displacement, U, which is not
parallel to the direction
that we're considering.
And the epsilon in a particular
direction is going
to be equal to the part of
U that's parallel to the
direction of interest divided by
distance in that direction.
And what this is going to give
us is the tensile component of
deformation in the direction
that we're examining.
Now, the radius normal property
works in this case.
And what the radius normal
property says, if you look at
a certain direction in the solid
and then look at the
normal to the surface at that
particular point, this will be
the direction of
what happened.
So I've not drawn
this correctly.
This should be the direction
of U. And this
is the radio vector.
So the normal to the surface
gives us the direction of the
displacement that's
going to occur.
And the reason I can say that
is by definition that that
property holds only for
a symmetric tensor.
And by definition, we have
defined the strained tensor
such that it is symmetric.
So the radius normal
property holds.
If we want to change from one
coordinate system to another,
we do that by the all for
transformation of a second
ranked tensor that, if we change
coordinate system, the
elements of strain change to
new values epsilon ij prime
that are given by cil cjm times
epsilon lm, the same law
for transformation of a second
ranked tensor that we have
seen earlier.
Finally, we can, because there
is a quadric, we can change
that by finding eigenvectors
and eigenvalues, take a
general form of the tensor
epsilon 1, 1, epsilon 1, 2,
epsilon 1, 3, and so on, and
by solving the eigenvalue
problem, convert this to a value
epsilon 1, 1 prime 0, 0,
0, epsilon 2, 2 prime 0, 0, 0,
epsilon 3, 3 prime to find out
what the extreme values of
tensile deformation are and
the orientations within the
original description of the
body in which these extreme
values occur.
OK, I'm just about
out of time.
I'll save until next time
another neat feature of the
strain tensor.
And that is contained within
these elements is information
on the volume change that
the body undergoes.
And this is something
called the dilation.
And we'll see that this is
related in a very simple way
to the elements of the
strain tensor.
OK, we've spent a lot of time
developing the formalism of
stress and strain.
And next thing we'll do is to
move on to some interesting
properties of crystals, which
are defined in terms of
tensors of rank higher
than two.
So we'll look at some third
ranked tensor properties.
That will include things like
piezoelectricity, the stress
optical effect, and things
of that sort.
These are going to be
really anisotropic.
Second ranked tensors were
anisotropic enough.
But the variation of property
with direction was a
quasi-ellipsoidal variation When
as 1 over the square of
the radius of the quadric.
For higher ranked tensor
properties, we will encounter
some absolutely weird surfaces
with dimples and lumps and
lobes, not this smooth
quasi-ellipsoidal variation, a
property with direction, which
was the case for second ranked
tensor properties.
So we will get into some exotic
anisotropies very
shortly to finish
up the semester.
So I will probably see some
of you at the MRS
meeting next week.
I won't see you on Thursday for
reasons that I need not
elaborate upon.
So I hope you have
a happy holiday.
Relax, suck in air, and come
back refreshed next Tuesday
for some really wild anisotropy
of physical
properties.